uh there is a very rapidly
um uh cons growing in concern movement
among the republican party
about how to get control of the party
back in advance of the 22 midterms and
certainly in advance of the 2024
republican presidential primary now you
might be saying well get control back
from who
uh or you might understand that the
question is about getting control back
from donald trump and there are a number
of interesting articles about this that
have come out over the last 24 hours one
such article in the washington post
reports about clashes between republican
leaders and the candidates that trump
has embraced and that these clashes have
been playing on playing out around the
country
a chaotic sign that trump's once
unchallenged hold on the party and rank
and file supporters is waning even by
degrees and i think at this point we
have to say
trump's control over the party is waning
but only to a degree in other words we
see that the number of republicans the
percentage of republicans that want
trump to run again is lower but it's
still not low it's still above 50
percent of republicans at last check but
interestingly the washington post writes
the former president's power within the
party and his continued focus on
personal grievances is increasingly
being questioned behind closed doors at
republican gatherings according to
interviews with more than a dozen
prominent republicans in washington and
across the country including some trump
advisors not surprisingly many spoke on
the condition of anonymity
because there remains significant fear
of attracting trump's public wrath also
being reported by business insider on
the basis of the washington post report
republican leaders are holding
closed-door meetings to question trump's
power over the party report says now i
think it's an important
reminder to to tell you guys
questioning trump's power is very
different than questioning trump's uh
questioning trump-ism or the sweeping
authoritarian slide that the republican
party experienced under trump but we'll
get to that in a moment a discontent
with trump is growing among some
republican leaders senior republicans
are questioning trump's hold over the
party in meetings some republicans
reportedly think trump's fixation with
election fraud could cost them in
elections i think the same thing and i'm
hoping that it happens
um and uh i think that the there's a
there's a few different things to talk
about here first of all
it's sort of like six years too late in
the sense that we would be living living
not in a different country
but on a different planet had
republicans had these meetings
previously now they kind of did have
these meetings early on in the
republican primary and ultimately their
voters chose trump anyway now could the
republican party have done more to
prevent trump from having become the
nominee in 2016 yes they could have done
more but it's possible that because you
know the the issue with the republican
electorate is that it's a monster of
their own creation
uh they attacked education for decades
they abandoned issues increasingly and
focused on cultural issues and talking
points and and this sort of thing and
what that led to in 2016 was a monster
that they couldn't even control could
they have turned the the ship around
uh once it was summer of 2016 i i don't
know i don't know if they could have
the um the other you know at the same
time the the the best time to plant a
tree is 20 years ago the second best
time is today if the republican party is
deciding it wants out of trump
uh okay they didn't do it six years ago
but they can start doing it now
the bigger issue here
is that
even if it's not in their best interests
to have trump represent the party
publicly
it doesn't mean that they want to
abandon the authoritarian non-thinking
reactionary slide that the party
experienced under donald trump they're
not questioning trump's authoritarianism
they're not questioning trump's disdain
for media and a free press they're not
they're not questioning any of that the
meetings are about is it good for the
face of the party to be trump doing
rallies complaining about the election
he lost 15 months ago it's about
the particular
person that is out there speaking
um prominently as the face of the
republican party and in fact i i would
say the opposite
they've become enamored over the last
six years
with this kind of hair-brained brand of
authoritarianism
and it's evident in that so many of them
are now stop talking about ron desantis
and falling in line behind desantis
desantis is just as authoritarian as
trump he's more competent than trump
which could make him potentially more
dangerous and effective as well so this
is not a republican um uh
sort of um
reaction
saying we've we've got to get away from
this authoritarianism and get back to
issues they're not saying that at all
um they're not saying wow we've really
tried to end
even the facade of democracy over the
last couple of they're all about all of
that stuff
they are just worried that trump at the
helm
is not best for them from a strategic
point of view they may be right about
that
but uh they don't seem to be concerned
with the actual direction of the party
they just want someone else at the head
of the party so
what effect will this have in november
of 2022 we just don't know yet and
donald trump at this point
i don't think has more rallies scheduled
but there's been talk about will he go
to colorado in support of lauren
beaubert one of the most
weaponized and dangerous
results of trumpism in the house of
representatives
what is donald trump going to be doing
uh in general between now and the
november election we will talk a little
bit later about one particular thing
that he's doing which is backing big lie
supporters
in positions of election administration
which is exactly what he said he would
do and he's doing it we're going to get
back to that but it could be a very
interesting match up here between
anti-trump republicans and trump going
into the midterms what can we hope for
as people on the left let's hope it just
messes them up and
limits the degree to which republicans
win in november if at all and of course
we're going to try to work on the if at
all piece
and avoid losing the house and senate
but remains to be seen